-Jimmy, thank you so much
for having me back.
I'm excited to be here again
and honored, Alex,
that you're joining us
for this very special
social distancing-friendly
"Hot Ones" experience.
And for those of you who aren't
familiar with the game,
it's pretty simple here.
It's an interview over
extremely spicy wings.
And as Jimmy knows,
it gets pretty spicy
pretty quick here
on "The Tonight Show."
-Yeah.
This is -- we're only doing
four wings this time.
I will say, by the way, you are
doing this online, right?
The quarantine for --
on your local --
on your normal First We Feast
channel?
-Yeah, we just dropped a special
quarantine edition.
We'll see, 'cause now we just
finished the season.
But, you know, still "Hot Ones:
The Game Show" on TruTV.
Still putting --
-Congrats on that, by the way!
-Thank you so much, Jimmy.
-What night is that on
again on TruTV?
-Tuesday nights,
10:00/9:00 Central.
-Congrats on that.
You deserve it, buddy.
It's a great show.
-Thank you.
-This is Alex's first time
doing this.
I didn't want to tell him
too much.
I won't tell him that much.
This will just be another
bonding experience
that we've had.
-Yeah, that's how it goes.
And the good thing is,
here on "The Tonight Show,"
we only do four wings.
Typically, we do ten wings
on the show.
Just four here,
that's the good news.
The bad news is it gets pretty
hot pretty quickly.
And this first wing,
Los Calientes Rojo,
is our midway mark.
So we're already starting
halfway up the mountain here.
-All right, and I know
how much sauce is on there,
'cause I did this myself.
-Wow.
-You can see it.
I mean, I coated mine.
I went for it.
All right, so this one is
just Los Calientes Rojo.
All right, here we go.
Cheers.
-Cheers.
-I like this a lot.
This is like a good
smoky flavor. I'm in.
-Not bad.
-Beautiful.
-All right, Alex, I'm going to
start with you.
You've obviously had an amazing
baseball career,
but you haven't stopped
putting numbers on the board
in your second phase
at A-Rod Corp.
What's one piece of
business advice
or something you picked up on
having spent so much time
around legendary Yankees' owner
George Steinbrenner?
-Surround yourself
with great people.
-Wow, that's good.
That's good advice.
-This is really good.
-Wow! You're going down
to the bone!
Dude, me too. I tried.
-All right.
Whole gang jumped in.
-By the way, I asked my wife
for some water for this,
and this is
what she brought me.
[ Laughter ]
It's a tiny -- it's like --
-I asked Jennifer
for some water.
She said, "Get up and get it
yourself."
[ Laughter ]
-It's like a shot glass.
-I love it.
-Well, that's actually a rather
poetic segue to this next wing
and this next question.
Here we're cranking things up
a little bit.
It's a green Thai chili sauce,
but it's been doused
in Carolina Reaper,
one of the hottest peppers
in the world.
-Mm.
-Definitely a little bit more.
-Like, your heat.
And then the Reaper comes in.
-It's tasty.
I'm going to put
a little more on.
-Real story,
Jennifer's behind you
giving me instructions
on how to eat the wings.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
She's like, "No, honey,
do it this way."
-"Pace yourself."
-All right, Jimmy,
that talk about the shot glass
that you have,
it's a rather poetic segue,
because with you guys doing
the "Tonight Show Home Edition,"
you've had to turn your wife
into your director
and camera operator.
And your kids, they're like
the graphics department now.
-Yeah.
-Has there been a moment
that you've forgotten
that they're family
and felt annoyed that they're
not doing their jobs right?
-[ Laughs ]
I could -- no, no.
I could never do that.
I mean, my wife is a rock star.
You know what she did?
She did, like, do this
with her neck as she was
filming once.
And I thought she was just bored
with what I was doing.
So, I was like, "Honey, what?"
And she's like, "What?"
I go, "You can't roll your head
or roll your eyes
while I'm doing a thing,
because it looks like
what I'm saying is boring."
But that was, like,
the only thing.
My graphics department,
they're kind of --
sometimes they phone it in.
[ Laughter ]
Like, this is not --
that's pretty bad.
That's pretty awful.
So -- but they're my kids so --
Yeah, they're not here
right now, so I'd say, yeah.
Do a better job.
This is a little --
that's a little --
they didn't care as much.
The first couple logos
were great.
And now we're -- you know,
we're at week seven now,
so that's happening.
Ooh, I'm feeling a little heat.
-Well, if you're feeling
a little heat now,
wait till you get to
this next one.
Jimmy, I know you love Da Bomb,
but here we brought
the Brain Burner along.
It's a sauce that's been
smokin' guests out
on "Hot Ones: The Game Show."
So, this one's a new one
for you.
-All right, ready?
Alex, go for it.
-Here we go.
-Ugh, that one you feel --
-Wow.
-You start feeling it
in your muscles.
[ Groaning ]
-Everybody --
-Uhh!
-Work it,
shoulders over here. Whew.
-Wow, whoo!
-Jimmy, believe it or not,
this is now our fourth --
this is now our fourth time
doing "Hot Ones"
on "The Tonight Show."
-Whew!
-I'm curious,
between past guests
Priyanka Chopra,
Selena Gomez, and J.J. Watt,
which guest was most upset
with you after the fact
for setting them up?
-Ah!
-[ Laughs ]
-Um -- they're all a little mad.
Ooh!
This one is so hot, dude!
-Wow.
-Oh, my gosh, my tongue
is burning right now.
Uh!
Um -- who was the --
Man, oh, man.
I think the more I exhale,
the more it hurts.
So maybe if I talk
by inhaling only,
it might be better.
Be easier.
And I'll exhale through my nose.
[ Gasps ]
That's the secret.
So I'd say that, um,
Selena Gomez was probably
the most mad.
When I went back into
her dressing room,
she was throwing up in a sink.
[ Laughter ]
And she had, like, spit
all over her --
from her mouth to the sink.
She was like,
"Get the F out of here!"
-Whoo!
-And she like, slammed the door.
It was insane, dude.
I was like --
I didn't know if she'd ever
talk to me ever again.
But she talks to me now.
[ Talking over each other ]
-I feel like I'm going to
replace Selena Gomez after this.
-Really?
You're feelin' it, right?
-Whoo!
-Oh, it is --
-A-Rod, does it feel like
a set-up to you?
-It does.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, man.
-Dude, this is when you
start feeling it.
It's like, oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
Ugh.
-All right, well, mercifully,
we're on to the last wing.
It's the Last Dab XXX.
And it's tradition around here,
put a little extra
on the last wing.
Just like this.
You don't have to
if you don't want to.
-I had that on there now.
My -- this is the first time of
me actually pouring these ones.
I gotta say, this Last Dab,
it's real thick.
-Ooh.
-All right, Alex,
you going first?
-Eh.
-Yeah.
-All right, you go
and then I'll go.
Cheers, guys, good luck.
-Cheers.
-Nice to see you guys.
Oh, my gosh.
-Ah.
-Lemony.
A little lemon.
Like, citrusy.
You can feel this one hit
the back of the throat.
-Ah!
-Oh!
-It scratches you --
Alex, how are you doing?
-I don't want to take
another bite.
-I got tears coming out.
-All right, guys, here we are
at the end of the line
and only one more hurdle
to clear.
And in true "Tonight Show"
fashion, we want to play
a little game with your brains
on fire and your tongues ablaze.
-Whoo!
-We have one of the greatest
athletes of all time sitting
right here, and Jimmy --
-Thank you very much.
-...what I want you to do --
-Oh, you're talking about Alex.
[ Laughter ]
-Jimmy, what I want you to do
is describe three athletes
without using their names.
And, Alex, it's up to you to
guess who Jimmy's describing.
-Who is the guy we were just
talking about, the documentary?
-Michael Jordan.
-Good. That's one.
Uh -- uh --
The greatest of all time, boxer.
-Muhammad Ali.
-Um, um, my writers
wanted to see if I can get
this one out,
threw me a curveball.
He's a golfer from the '80s.
-Tiger Woods, Jack Nicholson,
Nicklaus.
-His last name is like
an outdoor physical activity
you can play.
You need a lot of wind.
-Oh, Nick Price.
[ Laughter ]
-That doesn't make any sense.
-Wait.
-No, no, no, no, no.
It's an outdoor event,
you pull on a string with kids.
You run,
and it needs to be windy.
-A kite?
-Yes!
-Oh, Tom Kite!
-Yes! Thank you.
That's it right there.
We got it.
We got three, right?
[ Applause ]
-Bang, bang, three in a row,
with a little bit of assist.
And look at you guys, taking
down the wings of death
in the comfort of your
own homes,
but there's nothing comfortable
about what you guys
just went through.
Look at A-Rod, down to the bone.
An MVP experience
if I've ever seen one.
-[ Breathing heavily ]
Oh, my gosh.
You guys, thank you for this.
Alex, we have another thing that
we bonded over.
Sean, you are a maestro.
Dude, you are the best at this.
Congrats on the show,
on the game show.
TruTV Tuesday nights.
Guys, oh, my gosh, I don't know
what I'm going to do
for the rest of the day.
I'm hurting right now.
This is Alex's charity,
Feeding America.
Sean, I know you're working with
a bunch of charities.
I don't have yours out here,
but I love you,
and I'm about to leave
this meeting --
Zoom meeting, and I'm going to
drink this water
immediately after this, so
no one thinks I did it before.
I love you guys, I can't wait
to see you in person.
Thank you for this.
Jeez, gosh.
I'm freaking out already.
Can you see I'm crying?
These are tears.
-[ Laughs ]
-This is so real.
Oh, my gosh.
All right, thanks guys, bye.
Thank you.
-[ Laughs ]
-Bye, Jimmy.
-Oh, my gosh. Bye, bud.